My name is Bert Kreischer. And this is called. Ask the internet,
answer the internet. My name is Bert. Okay, good. Good.
Oh.
If you only had $5 to get drunk, what would you buy.
Nah, uh, no, I just, uh, give the fight out as a homeless guy. Now it's a $5.
I'm going to and do for me. $5 to get drunk. I would go and get, I don't
like Everclear or something. I'm maybe hand sanitizer. Yeah,
Listerine. I would get something really aggressive where I go. Oh, okay.
I would buy ingredients to make something. I couldn't. I $5.
Isn't going to do for me. How about, how about how many,
how many I'll tell you what? I'll tell you. What,
how much is a tall boy like to fit? It's gotta be like seven bucks.
I wouldn't even know three. Okay.
I get a tall boy. I get a tall boy.
Got a tall boy and a black and mild a cigar.
And I just inhaled the out of that $5.
The you gonna do with $5.
Would you rather give up porn or sex for one year sex
for one year? come on. I'm married.
I've pretty much given it up. porn. What am I going to do without born?
Oh my God. I don't even realize I'm watching porn sometimes I'm just in it.
And then I'm like, Oh, here we go. Here we go.
Have you ever seen quicksand porn because of you, right,
dude, I I'll tell you the creepiest porn I've ever seen.
Have you seen this stop porn stop. It's called stop porn.
It's a Japanese guy who has the power to freeze time.
So he's in an office building and he goes like, uh, uh,
magic Japanese word. Right. And then,
and then everyone just freezes and he just goes around and molests them as
they're frozen, but they're not frozen. They're actresses just going like this.
And he's just like, I can't do the Japanese accent. So I'll just be like,
he's like all top of the mountain until you this.
And then everyone's got come all over him. And he goes, I stopped,
stopped pulling. And everyone's like, why am I covered in
there's no creepiest. He like took one girl in later down,
but her legs stayed up.
Like this dude is who jacks off to that. This guy,
would you bang your cousin to win Powerball? The answer is a hot. Yes.
And my cousin Abe would be into it. He'd be like, how much are we winning?
We gotta do this. Cause all right, here we go. My cousin Abe.
One time we were in a, this is the way his brain works. One time we're in a,
in a train and the door's broken. It's just going. I am pant every time corner.
And he goes, how much do you think they give me?
If my arm was there and it got broken?
How much do you think I get for the train stations? I don't, I don't know.
He goes, think a million bucks. I said, Oh no. And he goes, let's find out.
And I go, you're going to break your hand right now. And he was like, yeah,
right. Not, I go, hold on. We're going to a Dave Matthews concert. Like,
I don't want you to have a broken hand. And he was like,
good call and just walked away. At one time, he goes, he comes in, he comes in,
we were having beers at this turf club betting on horses.
And he comes in and he goes, anyone want a Prozac? And we're like, you're,
you're on Prozac. And he goes, yeah, I go, I didn't know. You were depressed.
He goes, I'm not. I go, why are you on Prozac? He goes,
who couldn't stand to do a little bit better. Huh? So yeah, it would be a,
and I get myself worked up and then finishing them, like,
I'd be the starting pitcher and he'd just be, the clothes are just, Oh,
I just have to him. Oh, you just got to him a little bit.
And then I can fit in a nicer place in his
anyway. Okay. That's a better question. All right. What would you rather do?
What would you rather start a blow job pitch nine innings,
or just be the closer and catch the load? I
can't believe you're taking time on this. I'm catching loads.
I'm going to be like Lucy and the chocolate factory. Like
what are you doing? You can't think about swallowing.
You can't think about swallowing gum. He's got it.
He's got a little pit stomach. Is he throwing up?
Oh, I got to do it just a little.
My daughters are going to find this one day on the internet. Like, Oh,
I miss dad. Let me see that.
What catching loads in the mouth he's going to finish and cut uncle Abe.
Would you rather be the best looking dude in the world or be able to read minds?
Wow. Okay. Let's let's think this out. That's what you can do in the world.
It's gotta be nice. You can everyone. Everyone wants to give everything.
Everyone smiles. When they see you, as opposed to being ugly. When they see you,
they're like, can I help you, sir? As opposed to, Hey, can we to help you?
But if you read minds and you're just a regular person,
that's gotta be so painful all day that like, look at this fat. Oh,
I'm sure he's going to fart. I'm moving trains.
And then you'll be like, I would, I'd probably that guy. If I was drunk enough,
can you imagine his wife has, I mean,
imagine all this people would think about you. I'm going,
that's what you can do in the world.
I would love to see what it's like to like approach a stranger and have them
smile immediately and be like, Hey, nice.
You're not threatening at all. Yeah.
And then I'd have the guy that reads mine's next to me and goes, by the way,
she wants you to finger her. I don't even know her.
And the coronavirus is going around. I know just all the I think about myself.
I just hear other people verbalize it. Confirmed. Yeah. He's wearing God,
God, I can't believe you've performed with his shirt off.
Cause he told him his jeans story. Again, you get on stage. And they're like,
I was second that ladies and gentlemen Chrysler and I come out. They're like,
yeah. And all I hear is, Oh my God, he's gained weight. He's so bad.
I think his flight is going to go down. He's so fat.
As blinds are going to hold this long as a holding,
would you rather be drunk 24, seven or never be drunk again?
So if you're never drinking again, you miss out on sunsets
mornings in the airport. Uh, your dad's funeral,
every St. Patrick's day. Every time your wife says,
Hey, you want to put a bottle of wine and your heart skips a beat.
And you're like, it's exactly what I want.
You never get any of those now flip side, you feel fantastic.
Lose weight. You lose weight. You look good. You live longer.
Probably have more of a more successful career wherever you work,
wherever you do.
But you've got to sit on a,
on a bar, on a dock,
watch a sunset and have a diet Coke or like a seltzer. That's the worst.
Can I get a seltzer water and put a little splash of grenadine in there?
No, I know, right? By the way,
this is why I would never go into rehab is because I'm like,
that would be the guy going guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
We never get to see like a movie we haven't seen in a while and then go it.
I'm gonna get hammered for this like guy.
We sure.
Guys, we served guys. This is, I mean,
I'm hearing a lot of forever talk around here
or be drunk 24 hours a day.
Now here's the problem with being drunk 24 hours a day.
How drunk are we talking? Are we talking manageable? Are we talking about.
They uh, like could get a DUI, like, you know?
Okay, well I don't drive already. So we're we're by the way,
a lot of this is already going to fit into lifestyle. I've set up for myself.
You're going to go. Yeah. You can take Uber everywhere. Got it.
Living in a tour bus. Got it. Got it. Don't have a regular job. Got it. Got it.
Got it. Got it. You're going to gain weight. Been there, done that.
Doing it currently. Yeah. I would probably say, uh,
the problem is I get tired of alcohol at times where I'm like, where I'm like,
God, I need a break. Oh, can we smoke weed?
Yeah.
Let's I'll give you that loophole so you can get you just can't because yeah,
you can do other things. You just can't be drunk. Oh,
I can do other things like you go to your kid's event or something that has a
face. Dad, you can't, you know, I never thought of this as faced,
not shopping drinks as a valuable review where you'd be like, totally fine.
No one would even know.
Five, 10. Yeah. I could.
I could have, I could have, uh, I could have,
I had five beers yesterday morning and then not only did I not even feel it,
but it was aggravating. So like, I would hate to be that for 24 hours a day.
Like just how many of these is, are going to make it happen? Um,
I could probably have a sizable amount of alcohol show up to an event and no one
would know no one would know. And I, by the way, I've done that.
No one knew. And then my, my wife won't even know, like she couldn't even know.
So I brought it up to the 24, seven drunk, 24, seven drunk,
and then just continue on the path I'm on.
Yeah. She's worked out.
You rather date a girl who constantly sneezes on you or constantly farts during
sex
Constantly needed for the fun you. So anytime you're like, Hey, this is my wife.
You're like, God it. Nevermind. Or as you're or says,
I'm going to go forwarding. I'm going to go forwarding.
My wife had the door and oral sex one time and it didn't bother me.
It didn't bother me at all because I knew at least she's having an orgasm.
And I was like, that's it bring it home. Big guy.
talk about confirmation. We got the DNA.
We got all the swabs from the cheek and everything that happened.
That's an orgasm. When she almost on your chin, that's a orgasm.
That is a good orgasm.
You're like, ah, ah, you could have in my mouth.
give me a heads up. Firing the hole.
What movie most recently made you cry?
Uh,
there's a movie that has made me cry more than any movie in the entire world.
And you're going to go. Are you serious time? Traveler's wife.
Have you ever seen this?
No. I know the premise side dude.
There's a time Traveler's wife and the reason I'm in a bed, I'm in a hotel room.
I get out of the shower. It's on TB and I just I'm out of the shower.
I'm on the corner of the bed and I'm just watching.
And I'm seeing him feeling connections with this guy. Eric Bennett plays.
He's a guy who time travels by the way, I'm obsessed with time, trouble.
I'm really obsessed with time travel. He time travels more importantly,
he in order to stop traveling, time traveling, he drinks. So he drinks.
So he doesn't time travel. Right? So there we go. So I drink a lot,
but I go on the road. I time travel. And when he wakes up, he's totally naked.
That's happened to me a lot. Okay.
And at the end he finds out his daughter can time travel and his head of the
daughter and then he dies.
But he can still time travel into their lives from other points
in his life that he's leading in the past. So he's dead, right?
Oh my God. I'm getting chill, bumps. He's dead. And he comes out of the woods,
the same woods where he met his wife.
He comes out of the woods and his daughter goes daddy. And he's like, w what,
what time is it? What's going on? And she starts telling me, she goes, mommy,
he's here. And then the mom drops everything and starts running.
And all I can visualize is just like the you're on the road a lot as a dad.
And you're always busting your.
And then you do come home and your kids are like daddy. And you're like, Hey.
And you're like, wait, I've got to go. I've got to Tuesday,
got to get back out to Huntsville. Oh, hold on, hold on. Oh my God. I'm sobbing,
crying on the corner of a bed. Just my wife.
[inaudible] time. Traveler's wife.
I can't cry around movies with my daughters anymore because they call me out on
it. So like, if I start crying, they're like, Hey, someone's crying.
And I'm like, Hey, funny. I came in one time,
I was on the treadmill and I got a phone call that was pretty bad. I was crying.
And I walked in and they're like, Hey, dad's crying, mom. And my wife's like,
honey, dad's crying. We're all about to be crying in about five seconds.
And then I was like, they want us to put our dog down. And they're like, what?
It was like, that's how funny more you mother.
If you had the chance to the perfect girl,
but you had to do it with your entire family in the room watching what'd you do
well, the perfect girl is my wife and I would never do that.
But now we're talking like daughters, like your father.
He keeps the daughters in. This is what I can do.
What do you think about this? I run his family.
He's got the big [inaudible] uh,
perfect girl. Perfect girls like Kate up dinner or something. Oh no,
I don't know. We always say that. It's easy to think of the perfect guy.
It's so much easier to think of the perfect guy. There's so much option.
No problem. I was like, anyway, a woman
like Susan Surandon, Barbara Streisand,
Barbara Streisand, and uh,
Rita Moreno.
I think I would rather Danny DeVito in front of my family. Just,
I think they would just get a kick out of you'd be like, Oh gosh, shut up.
So Danny DeVito and like, what was he taking his pants off dad with the Holy.
That's [inaudible] get the out of here. I think he likes it.
They both like it. Oh, wow. Yeah,
Danny. It is. I can definitely Taylor Swift in front of my whole family.
And they'd be like, Oh my God, dad knows Taylor Swift police said, dad, his mom,
mom, mom, don't say a, you're going to this up for all of us. Okay.
If you just can, if there were,
if there was stats available for every aspect of your life,
what one stat would you want to see?
I had a dream the other day that, uh,
I dreamed very vividly that I,
we were at our new house and a truck pulled up and they dump truck,
dumped all of these bottles onto our front yard. And they're like,
this is all the alcohol you drank in your entire life.
And it was like a huge mound. And I was like, are you serious? And I'm like,
Oh no, no, I'm sorry. That's your wife's yours is coming. And I was like, ah,
I constantly say, I would love to know stats. I would love to know stats.
It's so funny. I don't even need to know stats about like,
I was just talking about this as a TV show the other day. Wasn't I like,
I want to know stats on like, um, like States.
I want to know stats about like, uh, uh,
this is how many people own guns in this state.
This is how many people do drugs in this state. Like,
I would love to know stats about everything stats about my personal life.
It would be cool. If you could tell, they can tell you how many you've taken,
but like that you could do some, be a game show.
So you'd get up there and they'd be like, all right, Burt, Kriser's here.
We're going to start off super easy burden.
How many times do you think you bourbon a day? And you're like, I don't know,
like three or four and they're like 19 and you're like, shut the up cigarette.
I went to the car one time. He goes, he said, he goes,
how many times do you think you burp in a day? And I went, I don't know,
like twice. He goes, you burped 20 times in the last 15 minutes. And I went,
are you serious? He goes, you burp a lot. Like, I'm noticing it a lot.
And then I started going, God it. I had to burp a lot, like in, that'd be cool.
And they'd be like, all right, Burt,
how many orgasms have you had by yourself? And you're like,
I'm going to say, what would you say? Maybe 10,000.
Let's do. Let's do real quick. How many days?
How many days in 30 years, how many days were there in
easy rain, man? How did you pull that? How did you pull that up?
What has it been a number of days in a year, times three.
That's about a thousand. That's three years. Sometimes 10 is about 30, so,
so easy numbers. And we still.
By the way, I still, I still don't know what math I'm doing.
I'm doing one I'm pretty much a one a day kind of guy.
That's uh, so for 10 years that'd be 3,650.
For 10 years is 3,650.
Once a day, three 65 times 10.
So I probably jerked off maybe like 10,000 times,
man. It's amazing. It's amazing that my Dixie's my hand company.
He doesn't know who chooses crews at this guy.
Sometimes I have to go. I sneak up behind them on my left hand.
I'll distract him to this hand. I'll be like, Hey, over here, my name is like,
what's going on? And he says, Oh God, he got in my mind. Oh,
this is going to be awkward too. Oh God.
Oh God. What's the other, the other hand is fingering his. Oh God.
I would love to see stats here. My stats. I'd like to see how many, uh,
how many shots I've done, how many beers I've drank, how many toasts I've made.
I want to know how many times I want to know how many times
I would love to see a stat on regrettable statements made by a drunk Bert
Chrysler.
And then I would love to pick that number and hear the statements come up.
I'm the only one in his family and Hollywood don't tell me about movies.
[Inaudible].